Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
podcast
on se retrouve pour le podcast hebdomadaire du samedi
donc cette semaine c'était une semaine très chargée
pour plusieurs raisons
la 1ère raison c'est que
vendredi dernier
on a déménagé dans notre nouvel appartement
on a déménagé dans un nouvel appartement
et du coup on a dû s'installer
ça a pris tout le weekend dernier
mais en fait on continue de s'installer
un peu tous les jours
comme on avait plus de meubles on avait plus de quoi
on avait plus de rangement
de bibliothèque
de table etc
on a du tout commandé petit à petit sur internet et
l'installer dans notre appartement
ce qui fait que même si on a emménagé
dans notre appartement
vendredi dernier
on a passé la semaine, pardon
à recevoir des cartons
à tout installer
à aller jeter les cartons etc
et pour vous dire
cette semaine
j'ai travaillé sur une table de camping
en plein milieu du salon
vide donc c'était assez particulier
et là techniquement je suis dans mon bureau
il y a peut-être un peu d'écho
tout simplement parce que c'est vide
et voilà là il y a plein de
il y a plein de paquets qu'il faut que je range
j'ai tout mis un peu j'ai tout entassé rapidement
mais il va falloir que je range un peu mieux mon bureau
donc beaucoup de
avec le déménagement
ça nous prend beaucoup de temps
d'acheter les meubles
de rechercher des meubles aussi de seconde main
donc des meubles d'occasion pour payer moins cher
et après tous les jours
il y a souvent des livreurs qui sonnent
qui nous livrent de nouveaux colis de nouveaux meubles
qu'on doit déballer
installer et en plus de ça il y a le travail
donc en fait on reçoit des trucs
on les entasse
et ensuite le soir
on passe notre temps à monter des meubles
à ranger à faire le tri
etc donc la semaine était très chargée
en plus du travail parce que
maintenant on a un loyer à payer
et du coup moi je ne peux pas ne pas
faire mes cours
et du coup là cette semaine
j'ai dû faire environ 25h de cours sur Preply
en plus de
voilà de ces vidéos que je fais sur ma chaîne YouTube
donc tout ça ça a demandé pas mal de temps
et en plus de ça cette semaine j'ai mon ordinateur
portable qui est tombé en panne
alors j'ai été un peu bête
parce que mon ordinateur portable avait un problème
il ne se connectait plus au au wifi
et en regardant sur internet
j'ai vu des conseils pour démonter l'ordinateur
et aller essayer de voir la carte wifi
donc le composant
informatique qui permet de se connecter à internet
et en fait en manipulant mon ordinateur
en l'ouvrant en essayant de réparer le problème
je n'ai fait que
je n'ai fait qu'empirer le problème
c'est-à-dire que maintenant
l'ordinateur ne démarre plus du tout
ce qui n'est évidemment pas du tout pratique
puisque c'est mon outil de travail
c'est avec ça que je donne mes cours
c'est avec ça que je fais mes montages vidéos
et que je publie sur les réseaux sociaux
donc ça a été assez problématique
mercredi
j'ai amené mon ordinateur portable chez un réparateur
qui doit me tenir au courant
savoir si il est réparable ou non
et si oui pour
à quel coût pour combien d'euros
en sachant que l'idée c'est pas de dépenser
des centaines voir €1.000 pour
réparer un ordinateur qui n'en vaut pas beaucoup plus
donc j'attends les nouvelles de ce réparateur
et en attendant
j'ai mon frère qui m'a gentiment prêté son ordinateur
portable mais du coup je n'ai pas vraiment accès
à tout ce que j'utilise pour mon travail
je peux donner des cours sur Preply
je peux poster des vidéos sur YouTube
mais pour le montage vidéo
il va falloir que je m'organise
avec ma femme
donc voilà entre le déménagement
le travail
mon ordinateur qui tombe en panne
mon ordinateur portable qui ne démarre même plus
c'était une semaine chargée
c'était pas évident
et donc pour ça
en ce moment j'ai mis en pause
un peu les réseaux sociaux
c'est-à-dire que je ne poste plus
sur Instagram et TikTok
j'ai envie de poster sur ces plateformes
mais seulement j'ai un peu mis de côté
j'ai mis en pause
pour essayer d'avancer sur le déménagement sur Preply
sur YouTube
et pour après
reprendre ces réseaux sociaux
tout simplement parce que pour l'instant
je préfère me concentrer sur YouTube
sur ces podcasts
je pense que c'est-ce qui est le plus
efficace et le plus
utile pour vous qui apprenez le français
donc je préfère me concentrer sur les vidéos YouTube
faire que ça
je ne poste plus sur Instagram et TikTok
et aussi j'ai eu beaucoup moins de temps
pour mon propre apprentissage des langues
comme vous le savez peut-être
si vous avez vu d'autres podcasts
j'apprends de manière régulière le japonais
et aussi le Portugais
il y a 1 mois début octobre
je m'étais donné un défi de d'apprendre
le portugais en 3 mois en étudiant 1h par jour
autant vous dire que je ne respecte pas du tout
cet objectif
actuellement je ne pense pas que j'étudie
1h par jour
et tout simplement parce que je manque de temps
pour le portugais
j'avais dit que je lisais Harry Potter en portugais
et ça je continue de le faire tous les soirs
mais au-delà de ça
je passe très peu de temps à faire mes
cartes de mémoire avec
l'application migaku
que je peux vous montrer
donc je ne passe
ça ne correspond pas du tout à l'objectif que
je m'étais fixé
pour le japonais
bon ça c'est un peu un travail régulier que je fais
j'ai pas forcément d'objectif là tout de suite
donc c'est pas un problème
mais pour le portugais
j'ai un peu l'impression que j'suis
en train de m'éloigner de mon objectif
que je ne vais pas y arriver
donc voilà un peu le style de carte que je fais
le matin je dois peut-être passer
15 minutes à faire mes cartes et le soir je dois lire 15
20 minutes donc voilà on est plus sur du
20 30minutes par jour
plutôt que sur du 1h et du coup
je n'ai pas le sentiment de vraiment progresser
et j'ai de plus en plus peur de ne pas réussir mon
challenge qui est d'apprendre le portugais
enfin du du moins d'être capable de parler en portugais
en 3 mois
donc bon à la limite
je me dis il faut pas que je me force trop
je préfère ne pas réussir l'objectif
mais de continuer à travailler mon portugais
c'est le plus important je pense
et en plus de ça à côté
mais c'est vraiment un tout petit peu
c'est je fais un peu de coréen tous les jours
j'avais envie d'essayer de voir
comment on lit le coréen
comment on lit l'alphabet coréen
et du coup
je continue de faire un tout petit peu de coréen
chaque jour environ 5 minutes par jour
donc vraiment pas grand-chose
voilà même le japonais en soi
je n'en fais vraiment pas beaucoup
j'aimerais en faire plus
mais bon
pour l'instant je me concentre sur le portugais
déjà que je manque de temps
pour le portugais
et donc tout ça
voilà cette semaine chargée
et ce
manque de temps pour faire ce que j'ai envie de faire
c'est frustrant
parce que j'ai l'impression de ne pas avancer
en ce moment enfin du moins cette semaine je pense
je n'ai pas l'impression d'avancer sur mon
apprentissage
personnel des langues
et je n'ai pas l'impression d'avancer
sur ma création de contenu
que ce soit sur YouTube
Instagram ou TikTok
heureusement
YouTube ça continue d'augmenter
les vues sont un peu en baisse
mais il y a toujours du monde qui vient
voir les vidéos
donc ça c'est très positif
mais j'aimerais faire plus
mais même si cette semaine a été très chargée
et que j'ai manqué de temps
on commence
quand-même à être bien installé dans l'appartement
on a reçu
donc j'ai reçu mon bureau
la caméra actuellement
est posée sur le bureau
et d'ailleurs c'est un bureau assis
debout donc je peux me mettre debout
je vais faire un petit test
voilà vous vous avez compris le principe
je n'en fais pas plus
on a reçu le canapé
actuellement
on avait juste une télé posée par terre dans le salon
sans rien pour s'asseoir
et du coup voilà ça commence à prendre forme
rien que moi le bureau
ça me permet de travailler directement dans mon bureau
et de ne pas être dans le salon
sur la table de camping qui fait office
de table à manger
et c'est tout de suite plus pratique
et du coup mon bureau commence à prendre forme
bon là la pièce elle est complètement désordonnée
mais je commence quand-même à
avoir le sentiment de travailler dans mon bureau
ce qui est plus agréable
bon là pour le pour filmer les vidéos
c'est un peu triste parce que tous les murs sont blancs
du coup ça fait un peu
ambiance hôpital
mais voilà petit à petit
je suis content
parce que je commence à avoir une pièce pour travailler
et pour ma femme c'est pareil
elle a son bureau
sa chaise et elle a commencé à décorer
sa pièce donc elle est très contente
là où avant quand on était à Paris
les appartements n'étaient vraiment pas assez grands
pour se permettre d'avoir un bureau chacun
donc pour ça on est très content
et du coup on commence à avoir
un peu le sentiment d'avoir un espace dédié
pour notre travail
et ça ça va être très important pour
ensuite continuer d'améliorer les vidéos
mes cours de français etc etc
et en plus de ça ben avec ce nouveau bureau
j'ai plein de de projets pour la suite
vous avez un petit indice là
j'sais pas si si vous voyez bien hop
mais du coup voilà j'ai plein d'idées pour la suite de
de cette chaîne YouTube
de mes réseaux sociaux
et même de
ce que j'ai envie de faire pour l'apprentissage
du français ces podcasts c'est un peu le
on va dire que c'est facile à à faire à produire
mais que par la suite
j'aimerais faire des choses un peu plus
un peu plus longues
un peu
un peu plus travaillées on va dire
et d'ailleurs
je pense aussi refaire des vidéos un peu scriptées
avant j'avais fait quelques vidéos
entièrement scriptées
c'est-à-dire que je lis un prompteur
je lis un script
c'est moins naturel que ce genre de podcast où je parle
sans script
*mince* en improvisation
mais avoir un script pour une vidéo ça me permet
de mieux maîtriser le rythme
et l'écriture
et donc ça peut aussi être très utile
pour votre apprentissage
du français dans tous les cas je pense faire les 2
je pense continuer ce genre de
podcast improvisé
et à côté de ça je pense reprendre des vidéos
un peu plus travaillées
un peu plus montées avec un script
qui soit un peu plus propre on va dire
je vais continuer à poster ce genre de podcast
2 fois par semaine
parce que je pense que c'est le plus important
actuellement pour vous aider à apprendre le français
et je vais reprendre les formats courts sur Instagram
et TikTok
et d'ailleurs je voulais vous remercier parce que
la chaîne
YouTube est devenue maintenant partenaire YouTube
c'est-à-dire que je peux rémunérer mes vidéos
pour chaque pub que vous allez voir sur mes vidéos
je vais toucher un peu d'argent de ces pubs
c'est assez difficile parce qu'il faut
1000 abonnés et 4.000h de vue
c'est surtout les 4.000h de vue qui sont difficiles
à atteindre
mais du coup c'est chose faite et YouTube a vérifié
a fait toutes les vérifications
sur ma chaîne YouTube
ce qui me permet de commencer à gagner de l'argent
avec mes vidéos
grâce à mes vidéos
bon on se calme parce que
ce matin j'avais le la 1ère estimation de la journée
il y a 2 jours je crois
et sur le total de la journée d'avant-hier
j'ai touché tenez-vous bien
20 centimes d'euros donc
c'est pas encore ça
je vais continuer à donner des cours sur preply
parce que je ne peux pas tout abandonner
pour mes vidéos YouTube
mais disons que c'est encourageant parce que
cette année
quand j'ai pris la décision de changer de métier
je voyais vraiment voilà
être prof de français sur une plateforme
faire du contenu
pour essayer de gagner ma vie
j'avais un peu peur que tout ça prenne beaucoup de temps
que je n'arrive pas à gagner suffisamment
pour vivre correctement
en plus maintenant on doit payer un loyer
donc on a des charges
mais
finalement pour l'instant ça se passe plutôt bien avec
Preply
j'arrive à avoir un certain nombre de cours par semaine
et là le fait que je passe partenaire sur YouTube
c'est quand-même un bon signal je trouve
et c'est motivant pour la suite
pour continuer à faire ce genre de podcast
si je postais mes podcasts et que ça faisait 30 vues
ça serait un peu difficile et d'ailleurs
toutes mes vidéos précédentes c'était un peu ça
je passais du temps à faire du montage
à faire des scripts etc
et pour au final que ça fasse même pas 100 vues
donc c'était un peu décourageant
mais là il y a de l'engouement
donc ça m'encourage à continuer ces vidéos
voilà j'espère que ce podcast vous aura plu
il va sortir donc le samedi
là je suis en train de le tourner le vendredi
et lundi je sortirai
unu autre podcast sous ce format
j'espère que mon
bureau aura avancé
que j'aurais pu ce weekend avancer
sur l'organisation de mon bureau
et de toute façon
je vais continuer à poster 2 fois par semaine
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et si vous avez aimé la vidéo
laissez un like un j'aime
et laissez un commentaire pour le référencement
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout
et je vous dis à lundi